مجددا تعود دراما العائله المالكه
البريطانيه وبسبب الامير هاري نجل الملك
تشارلز الثالث الذي وسعت الهوى بينه وبين
العائله المالكه نتيجه خلافات بدات منذ
زواجه بالممثله الامريكيه مجان ماركت اصدر
الامير هاري سيرته الذاتيه تحت عنوان سبير
والترجمه ربما احتياطي مع الترجمه حيث يصف
هاري نفسه بانه تمت معاملته كقطعه غيار
احتياطيه للتوريث في العائله المالكه اذا
ما اصاب شقيقه الامير وليام اي مكروه
ذلك بالطبعه قبل ان ينجب وليام ابنائه او
اذا اصاب اي مكروه شقيقه ويليام بالاحرف
ابرز ما كشفه هاري في كتابه هي مواجهه في
منزله في لندن مع اخيه وليام الذي ضربه
عام 2019 بعد ان تطور نقاش حاد الى اشتباك
جسدي ذهب ويليام الى منزل هاري للحديث معه
حول ازمته مع الصحافه ولكن يقول هاري ان
شقيقه كان فاقدا لاعصابه قبل ان يدخل
منزله اشتكى وليام من ميغان ماركل فقال له
هاري انه يردد الروايات الصحفيه
ويتوقع من اخيه ان يقف الى جانبه لكنه لم
يكن عقلانيا فندفع الشقيقان للصراخ على
بعضهما البعض قال هاري لاخيه انه يتصرف من
موقف قوه لانه الثاني في ترتيب العرش
انذاك وقال ان ويليام لم يفهم ابدا معنى
ان يكون مجرد قطعه غيار احتياطيه بحسب
هاري قال له ويليام ان ميجان ماركل صعبه
ووقح ومزيفه ليحتدم الحديث بينهما ثم خرج
الامير هاري من الغرفه وذهب الى المطبخ
وقال لوليام انه خائف منه لحق به وليام ثم
امسك بياخه قميصاري ومزق القلاده التي
تلتف حول عنق عنقه ثم طرحه ارضا يقول هاري
انه سقط بقوه على وعاء على الارض وتعرض
ظهره لاصابه قويه استلقى على الارض للحظات
ثم نهض وطالب شقيقه بالخروج من منزله
وليم لم يخرج طلبه ان يرد عليه الضربه
بالضربه كما كان يتشاجران في طفولتهما لكن
هذه رفض ليغادر وليام بعد ان اعتذر وطالب
هاري بعدم اخبار مجان ماركل بمحدث يقول
هاري انه لم يخبر زوجته بمحدث الا بعد ان
لاحظت وجود خدوش وكدمات على ظهره فاخبر
هذه هجوم شقيقه عليه لم تتفاجا ولم تغضب
ايضا يقول هاري انها كانت حزينه للغايه
بسبب ما حدث
[موسيقى]
بعد ذلك ينتقل هريء للحديث عن والده الملك
تشارلز الثالث وكيف تمت معاملته في صغره
كشخص احتياطي يروي قصه سمعها ان والده قال
لوالدته الاميره ديانا يوم ولادته رائع
لقد منحتني ورثا ثم قطع غيار
ثم يروي هاري لقاء جمعه مع والده وشقيقه
بعد جنازه جده الامير يقول ان والده وقف
بين بنيه المتحاربين وينظر الى الوجهين
الغاضبين ليقول ارجوكم يا اولاد لا تجعلوا
سنوات الاخيره بائسه
[موسيقى]
رغم هذه القصص المؤثره للامير هاري الا
انه لا يبدو انها تلقى الكثير من الاصداء
التي توقعها هاري بل تلقى الاصداء ربما
التي توقعها القصر حتى الان التزم قصر
الجديد حتى ان الخبراء المهتمين بالشؤون
الملكيه يرون ان القصر يتعمد الصمت تقول
كنزي سكوفيلد الخبيره في الشؤون الملكيه
ان العائله مرت بما هو اسوا من هذه الازمه
هذه حقيقه وتعتقد انه مجرد وقت قبل ان
ينسى الناس هذه القصه الجديده اما اذا رد
القصر فمعنى ذلك ان دراما هاري وماجين
ستمر اما الكاتب كريستوفر اندرسون الذي
كتب مؤخرا كتابا عن الملك تشارلز الثالث
فنقل عن مصادر قولها انها على اعتذارا من
القصر الا انه لن يحصل على ما يريد اما
بعيدا عن الخبراء فللناس ايضا موقف مشابه
حيث كشفت استطلاعات الراي الاخيره ان
الامير هاري فشل في اقناع البريطانيين
بهذه المذكرات ليجد استطلاع اجرته يوغاف
ان واحدا 81 بالمئه من البريطانيين لم
يهتموا بقصه حياه هاري اضافه الى انها
كشفت انخفاضا كبيرا في شعبيته
اصبرها يعني
لديك هاري وميكان الذين يكسبان عشرات
الملايين من الجنيهات لنشر غسيلهم القذر
في الاماكن العامه اعتقد انه امر صادم بغض
النظر عما يحدث بين افراد الاسره الملكيه
لكن هل تريد حقا نشرهاالى العالم
لكنني لا اعتقد انها بهذا السوق
لكن في نفس الوقت اذا حدث شيء ما عند اذن
يجب ان يعرف الناس
لديها مشاكل انا متاكد من انه يعاني من
مشاكل اكبر بسبب ما ولد فيه لكن لا تفعل
ذلك بهذه الطريقه يمكن القيام بحلها داخل
العائله لكنه اراد ان يعرف العالم كله
بغسيله القذر